it's actually a very surface  did piece of software  you know if you if you drop it in the  bath now it does not lose its data if  you get sand in it you can shake the  sand out and it doesn't impair its  function it continues to offer you its  information you can read it in quite low  light levels and in very high light  levels take it take that iPad out into  the sunlight and you can't read it you  know also it doesn't become obsolete now  you know whereas this new technology  becomes obsolete at the most remarkable  speed you know what's a floppy disk it's  like out of it  exactly it's like you know that what I'm  saying is that this thing which is  supposed to be the future now becomes  the past now at very high speed now  where is this thing which is supposed to  be the past now sticks around and  performs in the future now it's it so so  I think you know we've actually got you  know maybe we just put an apple on the  cover